good morning believe nation today's
message is commit passionately over
you'll be no children infrastructure
today there is a company called Hoover
who owns no car ok both Amazon and
Alibaba they own no warehouses or
factories or production facilities ok
somebody from Ukraine may come out with
an app which can change the whole world
and that app from who and I'm talking
about John comm who was the inventor of
whatsapp I mean you know he was working
literally as a sweeper in a with due
respect to him I promise you with any
profession you know I myself has worked
in very my sub level work that's not an
issue but you know it's an example of
from you may be born anywhere you may
have you may be may have a any kind of a
challenging background or a different
background but if you have that
commitment that vision that dream that
fire in the belly you can make it big so
listen up all of the different famous
entrepreneur and over and over again the
most consistent message that comes out
of everybody who's had success who's
reached the top in any of their fields
the most consistent message is not about
being outgoing is not about the
resources you have it's about having
passion for what you're doing passion
that's impression passion passion
passion has a passion passion passion
passion passion past an action
passion and here we hear it again from
another billionaire you have to have
passion and commit to what you're doing
and that will solve most of the problems
it's not about the money that you have
it's not about the parents that you have
it's not about the resources or
connections and what country you're from
it's about the passion that you have and
the willingness that you have to make it
happen whatever excuse you have in your
head whatever reason you have that you
keep telling yourself as to why you will
not succeed right why I will not succeed
write it down what's the gap right
because of blank what's in the blank
everything can be overcome by having the
ability to be passionate about what
you're doing and work hard
committing to achieving that goal that's
it so the question of the day today is
I'm curious what limitations have you
had to overcome that you thought weren't
possible that your friends and family
thought weren't possible because of
whatever restrictions you had what did
you have to overcome and did because of
the passion that you have for your
business super curious to figure it out
leave in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the conversation thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso